let's say that i have two numbers on a
number line so let me draw a little
quick number line right over here
and the two numbers on my number line
that i care about
the number a
and the number
represented by b here the way i've drawn
it b is to the right of a on our number
line and by our convention b is going to
be greater than a so if i wanted to
figure out the distance between a and b
what is this distance going from a
i want to draw a straight line here
this distance going from a
to b
so this distance right over there
how would i figure it out
well i could just take the larger of
these two numbers which is going to be b
and then subtract out the smaller so i
subtract out a and i'll be left with
this distance and this will give me a
positive value when i'm getting a d when
i want a distance i should think in
terms of a positive value how far apart
are these two things
but i was only able to know to do b
minus a because i knew that b was
greater than a this is going to give me
a positive value what if i knew that a
was greater than b well then i would do
the other way around so let me draw that
again let me let me draw another number
line right over here
and in this world
in this world i'm going to make a
greater than b so
this is
b
that is a and if i wanted to calculate
the distance between b
and a here
well now i would now i would take the
larger of the two a remember i want the
positive distance here and then i would
subtract out the smaller i would do a
minus b
well so here i did b minus a here i did
a minus b but what if i didn't know
which one was greater if i didn't know
whether b or a was greater what could i
do
well what you could do is just take
either a minus b or b minus a and take
the absolute value and if you do that it
doesn't matter if you take b minus a or
a minus b
it turns out
that regardless of whether a is greater
than b or b is greater than a or they're
equivalent that the absolute value of a
minus b
is equivalent to the absolute value of b
minus a and this is equivalent either of
these expressions is the distance
between these numbers and i encourage
you to play around with the negative see
if you can factor out some negatives and
think about the absolute value and it'll
actually make a lot of sense why this is
true in another video i might do a
little bit more of a rigorous
justification for it but i think the
important thing for this video is to see
that this is actually that this is
actually true so let's say we're in a
world let's let's let's get a number
line out and let's look at some examples
so let's say that we want to figure out
the distance
between
let's say negative 2
the distance between negative 2
and
positive 3.
so we can look at the number line and
figure out what that distance is to go
from negative 2
to positive 3 or the distance between
them we see is one two three
four five actually draw a straighter
line here this distance right over here
this distance right over here
is equal to
is equal to five you see it right over
here one two three four five or you
could go you'd have to go five backwards
to go from 3 to negative 2. but let's
see that what i just wrote actually
applies right over here
so if we took negative 2 to be our a and
3 to brb then we could write this as
the absolute value
of negative two
minus
three
minus three
what is this going to be equal to
well this is going to be equal to
negative two minus 3 is negative 5. so
it's the absolute value of negative 5.
and so this indeed equals 5.
so notice i subtracted the larger number
from the smaller number i got a negative
value but i took the absolute value of
it that gave me the actual distance
between these two numbers now what if i
did it the other way around what if i
took
what if i took 3 minus negative 2 so
it's going to be 3 the absolute value
of 3 let me do the blue color
the absolute value of three
minus
three minus and in parentheses i'll
write the negative two
negative two now if you take if you
subtract a smaller number from a larger
number you should get a positive value
so the absolute value sign here is just
kind of extra you don't really need it
and let's verify that that's true this
is going to be 3 minus negative 2.
that's the same thing as 3 plus positive
2 or 5. so this is going to be the
absolute value of 5 which of course is
equal to 5. so hopefully this makes you
feel good that if you want the distance
between two numbers you subtract one
from the other and it doesn't matter
which order you do it you can subtract 3
from negative 2 or negative 2 from 3 be
careful with the negative symbols here
and then take the absolute value and
then that is going to give you the
distance between these two numbers and
this is super important because later in
your mathematical careers you're going
to see a math professor just say oh you
know i care about the distance between
two variables you know a and b so the
distance is a minus b and then later
they might write it like this and then
to realize that these are actually the
same thing and these are they're going
to give the same expression the same
value and they represent the distance
between these numbers